hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
kochwelt ich möchte heute ein sehr
leichtes rezept machen
es gibt heute antipasti und zwar mache
ich gefüllte champignons und ich werde
sie mit frisch fit zu fühlen
das heißt es so ein rezept des chamer
vorbereite bei uns gibt's das jetzt auch
mal wieder als beilage zum grill
denn ich finde zum grillen gehört nicht
nur fleisch und gemüse also gemüsespieße
sondern auch so park alte sachen und das
ist jetzt was könnte vorbereite könne es
im kühlschrank lagern einfach machen wir
mitnehmen wo irgendwo hin wenn er zu
gast eingeladen seien und es ist echt
ein richtig leckeres rezept also wir
essen so antipasti auch immer ganz gerne
wir kaufen das auch oft beim
feinkostladen aber ich mache oft einfach
ganze aber wenn ich die zeit dazu haben
und ja das habe ich heute und morgen
teile ich euch das rezept mit
also ich werde heute die champignons für
den pc bereits 500 gramm
im prinzip ist egal ob jetzt weiß oder
braune hab ich habe mich jetzt für die
braune entschieden
dann brauche ich hier 200 g frischkäse
ich brauche etwas olivenöl eine zitrone
dann zwei esslöffel balsamico-essig
wobei ich jetzt ne balsamico creme habe
hier ein paar rappen news ein paar
schafe eingelegte etwas pfeffer und da
hat noch gewürze als ich habe jetzt hier
bisschen thymian bisschen chili rosmarin
salz und lorbeerblätter habe hier noch
frischem schnittlauch und habe hier noch
zweifach sehen denn knoblauch erschien
antipasti eigentlich immer mit drin und
ich kann jetzt schon mal mein öl als ich
nehme jetzt so etwa drei bis vier
esslöffel in die pfanne kann es gleich
schon mal erwärmen und nehmen sie die
champignons und wetter einfach immer den
stil herausnehmen dann braucht man
nämlich jetzt nicht müsste arbeitet
wegschmeißen sondern könnt es einfach
anders für werden falls ihr zum beispiel
demnächst eine lasagne macht oder
oder einfach mal zum rührei mit dazu so
könnte das einfach weiter benutzen
die nämlich jetzt kurz raus und dann
nehme ich mir auch schon mal die zwei
knoblauchzehen also bei mir sind es halt
richtig große das sieht man jetzt auch
hier richtig große knoblauchzehen also
im prinzip -zins 4 wenn man jetzt vier
normale nimmt und die werde ich jetzt so
im zwei drei stücke schneiden
gibt es somit rein und die champignons
die zwar auch direkt rein und die müssen
jetzt erstmal andünsten oder dünsten
bessert anbraten und die verlieren der
gleiche flüssigkeit wenn man gleich
wieder verdunsten standen zu finden
als er müsste pilsen knoblauch bei
mittlerer hitze anbraten sonst verbrennt
euch das know how und jetzt gebe ich
hier den balsamico mit dazu also löscht
das praktisch damit ab und schwenkte so
business damit die ganzen pilze mit dem
balsamico ebenso über reckte
jetzt warte ich einfach kurz bis es
nochmal verdunstet ist und dann sind die
pilze nämlich schon zu weit und ich kann
die gefühle aber die zeit nutze ich
jetzt um hier schon mal die füllung
vorzubereiten
und zwar brauche ich in brüssel zitrone
sein und den gebe ich mit zum frischkäse
also geradezu ein teelöffel dann nehme
ich hier ein paar rappen auf diesen ein
bisschen scharf roth für manche sind
wirklich sehr scharf ich finde so
mittelmäßig schaut und die schneide ich
jetzt klein
fuchs ich hab meine stilikone ist
mit seiner silicon.de drunter rutscht es
darf nämlich nicht
die gebe ich jetzt auch noch mit hier
rein dann schmecke ich den frischkäse
noch mit etwas pfeffer frischer
schnittlauch
geht am besten mit einer schere kräuter
schere wäre sogar noch besser was habe
ich nicht es gibt sogar was was ich
nicht habe
dann etwas rosmarin wobei den rosmarin
gebe ich lieber gleich komplett mit dazu
bisschen chili und etwas thymian und es
wird jetzt kurz verrührt wer möchte
könnt ihr zum beispiel noch etwas
paprikapulver eingeben dann wird die
creme nämlich rot
jetzt habe ich hier einen spritzbeutel
gerichtet mit einer großen loch schule
also wenn ihr jetzt keine tabus drin
habt könnt ihr zum beispiel sogar sogar
stern schule benutzen oder roxette und
stühle aber bei mir wird es jetzt nicht
geht weil die dann für stock gehört oder
püriert des halters es geht auch aber
ich bin dieses stück ich drin
der rat muss wieder vor den quatsch die
hintere kamera
jetzt könnt ihr hier die champignons
nehmen die sind jetzt noch warm ist aber
nicht schlimm nach wobei ich lasse doch
kurz abkühlen sonst mit frischkäse drin
denn das musik als kurz abkühlen
ich nehme sie außerdem auf der pfanne
raus geht's schneller in so eine flache
form und danach für nichtig
meine champignons den jetzt abgekühlt
und jetzt kann ich sie in meine form
umsetzen und dann einfach befuhren moore
hat mich vor ein ganz komisch angeguckt
nicht so schwarz
spritzerei
so kann man es übrigens auch habe mir
diese paprikas führen da gibt es diese
kleinen ich glaube kirsch paprika heiße
dies sogar diese natürlich richtig
lecker das ist so mein favorit bei
antipasti die muss man auch erstmal
kriege
und jetzt gebe ich hier noch ein
lorbeerblatt mit rein denn denn ich muss
jetzt die chance noch mit öl überdecken
und erst mal ziehen lassen muss
lorbeerblattes stecke jetzt einfach hier
und da rein so meiner meinung nach muss
natürlich dann noch mit chili mit rein
arbeiten mache ich mir am besten später
mit drauf wenn das ganze schon
durchgezogen ist gehört will mir alles
und man kann einfach jeder selber
bestimmen wird es haben möchte
also da gebe ich jetzt das olivenöl
drauf und dann lässt man das ganze im
kühlschrank noch mal so ein paar stunden
ziehen könnte auch über nacht machen
ohne der strecke meister wird ist später
nicht nur im olivenöl sondern schöpft
die pilze dann raus und es macht sie
halt dann auch haltbar und die
knoblauchzehe die stecke ich jetzt hier
auch mit rein activity nehme ich den
geschmack auch noch an soliden öl ab wer
jetzt will noch ein zweig rosmarin zum
beispiel ich sage das jetzt weg ich
möchte das jetzt ohne rosmarin aber so
eine frische 2 könnte ich mir ganz gut
vorstellen
und die werde ich jetzt gleich abdeckung
mit folie und wenn sie dann über nacht
stehen
aber hier habe ich schon eine kleine
kostprobe und zu sehen sie aus ich finde
die sind echt süß aus als sie danach zum
teller hat und dann kann man sich
sowieso als antipasti einfach der mund
stecken
echt gut
und ja ich habe jetzt einfach zehn
monate später phobien und ihr dürft das
rezept gerne nachlesen auf blog.de ich
freue mich schon richtig auf unsere
grillfeier und wenn ihr gerne noch
mccain rezepte sehen wollt oder so
beilagen zum grillen salate dips usw
schreibt mir einfach in die kommentare
das mache ich natürlich sehr gerne für
euch und ja ich wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß beim nachmachen und wir sehen beim
nächsten mal wieder biss dann jubelt
reiner